la droite n'avait sans doute pas besoin
de cela l'hypothèse d'un retour en
politique de l'ancien président
s'éloigne au grand dam de ses amis mais
finalement il peut être pas sûr que lui
même et tu envie tant que ça de quitter
son rôle de figure tutélaire guillaume
klossa ce procès qui s'annonce
ça veut dire que tout retour est
impossible pour une fois la sarkozie en
politique tout est toujours possible
sylla mais le problème c'est qui c'est
d'autant plus possible que vous avez les
forces et là les républicains sont
réduit à portion de chagrin et il avait
besoin de leadership et d'une figure
tutélaire et sarkozy était quand même le
dernier président qui a rassemblé les
français qui a été quand même très bien
élu en 2000 en 2007 et qui reste
respectée parmi les tous les militants
de droite et donc évidemment ça
fragilise à un moment où le président de
la république lui a une stratégie pour
finalement intégrer toute la droite
modérée au sein de la république en
marche et donc ça veut dire que il a sur
son flanc droit
emmanuel macron à une sorte de vide
politique sur son sur son flanc droit
ça peut continuer à faire travailler la
poutre comme dit notre premier ministre
en faveur de d'emmanuel macron
effectivement attirer encore davantage
la droite
côté macro est vidé de sa substance
encore plus les leurs oui déjà ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que voir un ancien
président de la république dans un
tribunal au banc des prévenus
c'est jamais très bon c'est pas bon pour
l'image de la france déjà c'est pas bon
pour l'image mais l'idée qu'on se fait
de la politique
voilà est-ce que pour autant cela
affaiblira c'est un nouveau coup dur
pour la droite
je ne crois pas alors où en tout cas
dans l'échelle des coups durs actuels
pour la droite ce n'est pas forcément le
nom c'est pas forcément le plus dur quoi
faire parce qu'en réalité parce que en
réalité le principal problème de la
droite aujourd'hui c'est que finalement
une bonne partie de ses électeurs
trouvent que le meilleur défenseur de
leurs idées c'est à dire du libéralisme
économique et de l'intransigeance social
c'est emmanuel macron est il donc ils ne
voient pas l'intérêt aujourd'hui de se
tourner vers la droite et en plus il
faut tenir compte d'une chose c'est que
nicolas sarkozy vous avez raison il est
très populaire parmi les militants et
même parmi les électeurs de droite et
plusieurs enquêtes qui l'attestent
et pourtant et pourtant il a perdu la
primaire
l'interview de la primeur de voiliers
faut évoquer effectivement sa victoire
en 2007 il a été élu sur un programme
qu'il n'a même pas commencé à mettre en
oeuvre donc la ligne politique qui était
celle sur laquelle il a gagné en 2007
il ne l'a pas du tout mis en oeuvre
pendant son quinquennat ou quasi pas
donc là dessus il a perdu une grande
partie du leadership est effectivement
ensuite cet échec
quand même cinglant à la primaire de la
droite où il est arrivé quand même
troisième c'était une façon pour les
militants d' exprimer leur rejet de la
candidature dit s'appeler la populace et
quand on ne s'exprime pas en tout cas
dans les urnes non non seulement inscrit
pas dans les urnes mais je pense
qu'elles s'expriment pas autant qu'on le
dit même au niveau de la base militante
des républicains nicolas sarkozy est une
figure qui effectivement à un moment
donné à rassembler la droite mais cette
droite là c'était l'ump
deux des années du milieu des années
2000 aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy ne
représente plus grand chose en réalité
pour la droite qui reste à construire ou
pourrait effectivement cette droite qui
est aujourd'hui a été complètement
aspiré par la république en marche par
cette ouverture extrêmement puissante
vers la droite juppéiste et finalement
monsieur sarkozy se rapproche davantage
d'alain juppé que il ne se rapprocher de
la ligne fillon ou de la ligne voces
donc la cohérence veut que nicolas
sarkozy avait plutôt vers emmanuel
macron que de ressurgir comme ça dans la
vie politique française où finalement je
ne crois pas du tout qu'il soit attendu
pourtant marc landré on dit souvent
qu'ils continuent à tirer les ficelles
qu'il est très consulté très écouté je
fais la comparaison avec le par le film
fameux film gier corleone il avait été
condamné
et pourtant ils continuent à tirer les
ficelles dans l'ombre on n'a pas besoin
d'être numéro 1 pour avoir un poids dans
une société qu'on contrôle effectivement
aujourd'hui c'est une figure tutélaire
c'est un sage qui continue à tirer
quelques ficelles mais on voit que
finalement il en tire plus tant que ça
parce que wauquiez il était d'accord
pour le maître et il s'est viandé dans
les grandes largeurs
bellamy il le connaît pas il le
connaissait pas il l'a pas soutenu de
façon très vite nommé il a pas donc le
cracher dessus je dire c'était sûr sur
des petites considérations comme de
choix de candidature il a pu énormément
en influence ou en tout cas si une
influence yale il a on la voit pas mais
de toute façon je pense que c'est un
fantasme que de croire que toujours
croire à l'homme providentiel ou retour
de l'homme providentiel c'est pas parce
qu'il a gagné il ya 12 ans qui seraient
capables de gagner aujourd'hui vous
l'avez dit on l'a vu aux primaires de la
droite ça n'a pas marché ça n'a pas
fonctionné laura avait été perdu et en +
gyr aujourd'hui on semble découvrir que
nicolas sakozy de les problèmes
judiciaires
il a eu cette casserole suite à sa
défaite en 2012 parce qu'il fallait
qu'ils ne soient plus prises en
république pour pouvoir être poursuivis
il en reste deux il lui reste les deux
casseroles dont on sait depuis le début
3 3 3 mais particulièrement sérieux
l'hypothèse d'un financement est bien
mais au milieu des affaires de
corruption et d écoute et quand même la
plus sérieuse aujourd'hui avec ses
gosses judiciaire jeudi en parlant
pratiquement et je discerne pas parce
que dans l'opinion publique c'est pas
celle qui qui choque le plus aujourd'hui
franchement avoir favorisé avoir comme
président de la république favorise
plutôt telle nomination que tel autre
et en plus il se trouve que celui qui
est censé avoir été favorisée finalement
n'a pas été nommé jeu franchement je
suis pas sûr que c'est celle là
qu'aujourd'hui contient aucun nom mais
non merci pas son america mais mais
quand si on demande aujourd'hui aux
français quelles sont les affaires dans
lesquelles sont impliqués
nicolas sarkozy on vous répondra
bygmalion les que le dépassement des
comptes de campagne et la libye voilà on
vous parlera pas de la sanction du judo
monaco qui sait peut-être sur cette
affaire là qu'il sera condamné alors que
sur les deux autres pour l'instant c'est
très difficile de trouver et en plus bas
à partir d'écoutés qui sont plus ou
moins illégal quand même été légalisé
voilà oui mais c'est pas encore tranché
ça le sera à l'audience
finalement les choses de manière
différente il suggère finalement le
dernier représentant de la droite
traditionnelle historique passe la main
et ça ouvre la porte à une nouvelle
génération parce que la politique a
horreur du vide
en quelques mois des gens peuvent
émerger rappelez vous la voyez on la
voit pas aujourd'hui mais la manière
qu'on voyait ça ça veut dire que la
droite est confrontée pratiquement
unique uniquement un problème de
leadership la personne je ne crois pas
je ne dois pas elle a un problème de
définition de définition un socle des
valeurs d'identité de ligne politique
plus que deux personnes et biens
jusqu'au 11 mai généralement les deux
arrivent ensemble c'est à dire que il ya
quand même des gens second si vous avez
la droite centriste qui est au pouvoir
avec emmanuel macron et qui a
complètement aspirer tout le quand je
lis ça résiste mais parce que le camp
juppéiste et le camp sarkozyste à peu
près le même quand c'est un peu mou du
ray le sujet de savoir quels défis que
la loi qu'est ce que la droite
conservatrice
est-ce que tout le personnel
affilée pour rassemblement national ou
est-ce qu'il ya encore un socle de gens
qui finalement ne vont au rassemblement
may sur evre que faute de 2007 c'est une
question bien sûr parce qu'il faut pas
regarder un petit peu on fait en rien
nos internautes et vous avez la parole
ensuite la question que vous posez
bientôt jugés pour corruption nicolas
sarkozy peut-il encore faire figure de
recours pour la droite
vous dites non à 73% donc assez sévère
effectivement nos internautes
hugo nous dit sarkozy n'a plus d'espacé
de crédibilité politique
babineau le destin de sarkozy n'aura
aucune incidence sur la vie politique la
droite a choisi son nouveau champion
macron il vous rejoins donc plutôt johan
la droite n'est pas morte elle est en
sommeil je parie sur l'effondrement de
la république en marche avant en 2022
je voulais qu'on parle aussi un petit
peu de et je vais vous faire réagir à
deux interviews qui ont être celle de
kessel de claude guéant d'une part qu'on
va écouter lui parle d'acharnement des
jeux s'est pas dit mais c'est comme ça
qu'il le mange on écoute claude guéant
ancien directeur de cabinet de nicolas
sarkozy jeudi j'ai ma tristesse et l
égard de l'homme mais c'est aussi à
l'égard de l'institution parce qu'il a
été un président de la république et je
trouve qu'il y a depuis quelques années
déjà une sorte d'acharnement globale
pour que tous ceux qui ont des
responsabilités politiques dans ce pays
et c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui se
trouve déstabilisée c'est grave aussi
ressaisi le système acharnement global
c'est une façon polie de dire
acharnement contre nicolas sarkozy
je fais que le système judiciaire marche
en france c'est plutôt une bonne chose
c'est la démocratie fonctionne plutôt
bien dans notre pays le système
judiciaire aussi donc pas je parlais pas
d'acharnement global mais je pensais en
gestion continuer notre discussion sur
qui peut incarner une droite rénover la
façon dont les juges parce que c'est une
fille tu de vous l'avez remarqué eu
cette procédure
aujourd'hui qui perdure parce qu'il ya
parce qu'il y avait matière à enquêter
conduit d'instruction et au final il ya
eu des non lieux il ya eu des amap site
de bois quand on est quand on est un
dirigeant politique et a fortiori le
président de la république
évidemment qu'on est une cible
potentielle de la justice évidemment
mais raison de plus pour être
irréprochable
raison de plus pour être pour
précisément ne jamais avoir affaire à la
justice
mais mais l'idée que parce qu on est un
homme politique on serait une cible
potentielle plus plus important que
n'importe qui d'autre sur certains des
affaires ben oui c'est vrai ça bien sûr
que c'est vrai c'est pourtant aussi la
vie en filigrane de jean leonetti qui
assure aujourd'hui la présidence par
intérim des républicains on écoute
d'abord j'espère comme dans mon pays la
justice est indépendante
voilà vous n'avez pas sûr que je
l'espère en référence aux fortes 1 et le
deuxième point c'est que jusqu'à présent
et vous l'avez noté nicolas sarkozy
malgré tout ce que vous évoquez n'a
jamais été condamné
donc je reste dans nos petits qui
consiste à dire que des gens qui sont
pas condamnés sont présumés innocents
dans mon pays c'est toujours étonnant de
voir
je pense surtout à monsieur guéant venir
nicolas sakozy judiciaire le problème
c'est que ça décrédibilise quand même
largement la classe politique ont en
tout cas une certaine classe politique
et je trouve ça assez assez regrettable
parce que l'état de notre démocratie
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer est en très mauvaise
posture
donc je pense que tout cela aura des
effets extrêmement délétère sur
l'opinion et ne pourra encore une fois
que venir grossir les rangs du premier
parti de france c'est à dire le parti de
l'abstention c'est l'attaqué je suis pas
sûr je pense qu' une proximité
intellectuelle entre nicolas sarkozy
emmanuel macron et que le système
judiciaire n'est pas contrôlée par le
politique pour attaquer nicolas sarkozy
que c'est très difficile comme comme
contre attaque de dire de dire ça et
emmanuel macron n'a pas forcément
intérêt non plus à
fragilisée nicolas sarkozy il n'y a pas
de ya pas de mieux vaut mieux vaut qu'il
est encore un petit socle à droite que
rien du tout donc je pense qu elle pas
d'intérêt objectif est que il faut pas
fantasmer là dessus il faut que la
justice pour suivre son cours et voilà
et on peut retourner les choses c'est à
dire que les deux derniers grands
champions de la droite que sont nicolas
sarkozy et françois fillon
on se retrouvait dans un prétoire
prochaine lang j profitons-en pour
tourner une page tourner une page sur
les sommes donc allés au passage de
novell la nouvelle génération est aussi
sur les idées puisque les idées
aujourd'hui elles sont mises en oeuvre
par emmanuel macron donc le peu après
après dans les équipes d' emmanuel
macron il n'est pas dit non plus que
certains membres dans la sphère benalla
ne soient pas eux mêmes aussi poursuivi
donc il faut pas s'imaginer que les
trois mêmes accroc il ya ceux qui
gouvernait qui dirigeait la france y est
l'exemple avec le tandem sarkozy-fillon
du monde il ya toujours eu et il y aura
toujours des affaires en politique
partout donc malheureuse aux tic c'est
comme ça le lendemain n'a pas m'aimer
non mais ce qui l'est en revanche c'est
beaucoup moins acceptable qu autrefois
parce qu'on exige aujourd'hui de nos
dirigeants une intégrité une exemplarité
qui est qui est beaucoup plus grande que
eux mêmes la revendiquer
parce que là même la revendique campagne
et que et que la société aussi voient
ils comparent et de mieux en mieux
informés aussi ses promesses que même la
revendique donc la matte de la
démocratie est plus mature et donc c'est
normal que tout est affaire apparaissent
alors par ba papa nous dit j'admire la
carapace de monsieur sarkozy pour
résister à toutes ces accusations
infondées contre lui c'est son avis et
le nostalgie qui n'a pas trop de souci à
se faire puisque il ne sera pas jugée
avant de très longs mois
sauf erreur de ma part ne s'est pas
encore audience et mais on parle des
prochains mois donc ça devrait pas non
plus être dans si longtemps que ça alors
maintenant on va parler un petit peu
d'europe qui va succéder à jean claude
juncker à la tête de la commission
européenne
c'est la question qui agite les leaders
européens
aujourd'hui et demain à bruxelles et
c'est une vraie bagarre dans laquelle
emmanuel macron a perdu sans doute
plusieurs atouts ces derniers temps il
n'arrive pas vraiment à prendre le
leadership du tandem franco allemand est
à bruxelles les eurodéputés en marche
ont été affaiblis par les propos
ravageur de nathalie l'oiseau emmanuel
macron qui est arrivé en début
d'après-midi à bruxelles et qui décrit
ainsi le profil type de ces nouveaux
responsables européens il faut des
personnes qu'ils aient les compétences
qui partage ses ambitions qui a
crédibilité pour le faire et je
soutiendrai les figures les plus fortes
à cet égard que pas toujours le fort de
l'est prochaine il ajouté
mais mais mais tu ce que l'art a ajouté
le président du conseil européen donc
dans la feuille d'eau dans les
propositions qui doivent être faites
il faudrait qu'il ya de femmes sur les
cinq postes pour voir parce qu'il ya en
effet la parité calcule bien alors on va
dire qu'il ya quatre postes à pourvoir
plus en plus un mais il pourrait même y
avoir trois femmes sur les cinq postes
donc cote quand c'est un nombre impair
pas sur leurs qualités femmes mais mais
mais rappelez-vous ce que disait
françoise 0 conduire à une femme
incompétente au plus haut niveau c'est
là que l'égalité alors justement est là
ou pas
elle a multiplié les fautes fait les
premiers pas très raté son entrée
l'union européenne va imposer enfin moi
je pense qu'on a une responsabilité
collective parce que j'ai eu dans la
presse pendant des mois qu'elle était
compétente technicienne diplomates etc
en tout cas les arguments tous les axes
mais ce que ces camps mais pardon mais
ce que disaient aussi le journaliste et
mon sentiment est que pour un poste j'ai
été conseiller spécial pendant la
dernière présidence française